[Music]
starwars a new hope is one of my
favorite films of all time it shaped the
science-fiction genre became a
multi-billion dollar franchise and was
even nominated for Best Picture though
many say the reason Star Wars is so
memorable are the characters what you're
talking about though the reason we keep
coming back time and time again and then
the grand pantheon of film characters
everyone knows who Han Luke and Leia are
the same can't be said for others yeah
but it's one thing to say we love these
characters it's another to examine why
we love them I don't know who you are or
where you came from
now on you do as I do you okay so in
this video I want to examine character
arcs specifically how they propel our
characters forward create engaging plots
and ultimately an emotional narrative
that makes us universally connect
whether you're a fan in the United
States Europe Japan or elsewhere first
we need to examine what exactly a
character market is many beginners
screenwriters mistakenly confuse arc
with change thinking that as long as my
protagonist changes in some way boom I
have an arc push on us this thinking is
problematic primarily because it misses
one of the most important elements of a
story its theme in her book creating
character arcs am Wyland muses quote not
only do character arcs directly
influence story structure they're also a
direct influence on theme in some
respects we might even go so far as to
say that character arc equals theme now
this is important because if you're one
of the millions of Star Wars fans out
there who likes the film's because of a
the characters or the the story you are
essentially saying the same thing
because character drives the story they
are inextricably linked a story on the
other hand where the plot does the
driving leaves you with mechanical or
inorganic characters
a theme is essentially a unifying or
dominant idea that shapes your story and
it should be summed up in one easy to
digest sentence in Macbeth for example
the theme is ruthless ambition leads to
one's destruction and why not throw in
another Scottish example Braveheart
where freedom is worth fighting for even
if it means to the death
[Music]
Lajos agree and his masterwork the art
of dramatic writing calls theme your
premise and argues that it should be the
first thing you think about before
writing for it shapes and drives every
aspect of your story without a theme
without trying to argue something you
believe to be true why bother writing in
the first place so how does this tie
into Star Wars well
themes play a large role in the Star
Wars universe as George Lucas said while
writing it's about good and evil but
heroes what makes a hero what friendship
what's the idea of sacrificing yourself
for something larger they're all really
basic things they're simple don't have
to make a movie about that it's very
obvious but it's actually not writing
themes through character arcs are
definitely not easy but let's take a
method used by Weiland to break it down
using star wars a new hope as an example
wildin argues that in order to shape
your characters arc you must first know
for things your character's want/need
lie and ghost let's take a look at these
more in-depth and apply them to the
character of Luke Skywalker so what do
we start with first let's start with
what wildin calls the quote foundation
of character arc the lie the lie is
something that your character believes
to be true about the world or himself
it's an outlook on things but something
about this outlook is wrong or misguided
when you know what this is you can sort
out how to make it right so what is the
lie Luke Skywalker believes Luke
believes that his life isn't going
anywhere that he'll likely end up a
simple farmer like his aunt and uncle
there isn't anything special about him
but maybe just maybe he'll be able to
eke out a life if he can make it to the
Academy and if these new droids do work
out I want to transmit my application to
the Academy this year a dream put on
hold when his uncle asked him to stay on
for another season promises when I need
you the most
this lie is also heavily influenced by
the thing that is lacking in your
characters life take a look at one of
the most iconic scenes from a new hope
this is a great scene because it conveys
so much with so little there isn't even
any dialogue in fact even though the
scene is 38 seconds the shooting script
reads with only
two sentences Luke dreaming of a world
beyond his own stares into the horizon
at worlds beyond the music swells giving
us a sense of hope until his head lowers
the music changes he succumbs to the
realization that that is in his life it
is in fact a dream but why is it that
Luke believes this lie for that we must
examine the second characteristic of
story-arc the ghost the ghost is the
reason your character believes the lie
some call it the wound and it usually
refers to a traumatic experience in your
character's past that is shaped the way
they view the world now this is a
component of backstory something we
don't get a lot of and a new hope and
when we do it's largely expository how
did my father die
Luke's ghost is the death of his parents
which shape his outlook on life because
of this event even though he never
personally witnessed their deaths it
leads him to believe his life will be
nothing more than a Tatooine farm boy
he'll never get to be a great fighter
like his father because well his father
isn't around and damned if he isn't able
to help his uncle own with another
harvest Luke just not a farmer oh yes
too much of his father in him in Empire
Strikes Back when Luke finds out that
Vader is his father it hits him and us
the viewer especially hard because we
subconsciously feel that his lie was
based off another lie the lie that his
father was dead and the reason why that
twist is one of the greatest if not
greatest plot twists in cinematic
history is because of its embeddedness
and character art an idea worthy of a
video of its own so once you know your
characters lie and ghost you can set up
ways to change the lie but in order to
do this your character will need a
reason to change for that we look at the
third characteristic of the character
arc the wand
once are that thing your character
desires more than anything else they are
the fuel or motivation that causes your
character to act and propel the story
forward for a more detailed explanation
of wants check out my video on the
differences between want and need in
Star Wars Luke has a very easy to
identify wand
in fact he states it clearly at the
beginning of act 2 I want
the ways of the force and become a Jedi
like my father Luke's desire to become a
Jedi like his father is what will
eventually drive him closer to the main
antagonistic force Darth Vader his want
additionally creates certain and
pathetic qualities he wants to be like
his dad leave this farm boy world behind
and explore the great unknown I could do
a whole video on creating empathy and
characters but needless to say many of
the main and secondary characters in the
original trilogy are filled with such
empathetic qualities or qualities that
make us relate and care about them back
to once it's important to note that
they're only as good as the obstacles
that get in their way
if there was nothing in the way of Luke
becoming a Jedi there wouldn't be any
story in a new hope Luke has met with
several obstacles from needing to find a
way off Tatooine 10,000 miles by
ownership for that or getting sucked
into the tractor beam of the Death Star
there gotta be something even dude
narrowly being crushed into a trash
compactor and how can we forget Darth
Vader himself I'm taking an awful risk
Vader a new hope is also an interesting
case study because it sets up both a
trilogy want and an episodic want luke's
trilogy arc his want that spans episodes
four or five and six is to learn the
ways of the force and become a Jedi
Master we see this continued in Empire
Strikes Back under the tutelage of Yoda
and Return of the Jedi where Luke must
use everything he has learned from
episodes four and five in a final
showdown between his father Darth Vader
but the individual episodes of Star Wars
also need their own closed stories
Luke's wanted a new hope is to save the
princess and destroy the Death Star
Skywalker I'm here to rescue you he
accomplishes both these things by the
end but is far from reaching his trilogy
goal of becoming a Jedi Master and
defeating the Empire once also need to
be backed by stakes in other words what
will happen if our character doesn't get
what he wants for Luke if he doesn't
destroy the Death Star it could mean the
complete annihilation of countless
planets as was evidenced with the
destruction of Alderaan and if he
doesn't become a Jedi Master who will
provide a balance to the evil empire
having your character wants something
backed by stakes with obstacles that get
in his or her way is only the first step
to creating memorable characters and
most writers make the mistake of
stopping there in addition to want your
protagonists must have a need this is
something that they need to figure out
about themselves if they're going to get
the thing that they want in a new hope
Luke needs to believe in himself and
trust in the force if he doesn't do that
he'll never end up becoming a Jedi and
defeating the Empire let go your
conscious self an act on instinct the
need like a wand must also be presented
with obstacles and in most stories that
obstacles to a need is the character
themselves it's internal in Luke's case
it's his own self-doubt in fact when
presented with the opportunity to leave
his simple farm life behind and go on an
adventure he rejects it and not only
that he rejects it three times I've got
work to do it's not that I like the
Empire I hate it but there's nothing I
can do about it right now in his book
the writer's journey Christopher Vogler
calls this the refusal of the call
stating the problem of the hero now
becomes how to respond to the call to
adventure put yourself in the hero's
shoes and you can see that it's a
difficult passage you're being asked to
say yes to a great unknown to an
adventure that will be exciting but also
dangerous and even life-threatening and
Luke goes on to make a sorry list of
excuses as to why he can't go on the
adventure even though subconsciously
he'd want nothing more and it is only
when the adventure is brought to him
that he answers the call because this
time it's personal
we also see Luke taking small steps
towards achieving his need this mainly
occurs under the mentorship of obi-wan
and the beginning of his training
training which was cut short at the end
of Act two
and later picked up by Yoda in the
Empire Strikes Back
Luke's need isn't just tested in a new
hope it will be tested both in Empire
Return of the Jedi I am a Jedi like my
father before me and even the last Jedi
now that we've identified the four
characteristics of character arc let's
examine how we naturally arc the
character so that when they have changed
into the new better self
it doesn't feel awkward stilted or
mechanical in character arcs and
especially in stories such as a new hope
it's important to know the difference
between a reactive and proactive
character at the beginning of a new hope
Luke is reacting to the world around him
blinded by his lie which prevents him
from taking action and makes him refuse
the call I can't get involved
I got work to do as the plot progresses
he will eventually be confronted by
events which will force him to confront
his lie and eventually accept the truth
if we look at the first act of Star Wars
it's essentially a series of events or
plot points in which things happen to
Luke and he reacts to them Luke acquires
the droids reacts Luke searches for
artoo after he goes missing reacts Luke
is saved by obi-wan reacts and finally
Luke reacts to the death of his brutally
murdered aunt an uncle by joining
obi-wan on his journey to Alderaan
for almost the entire first half of the
film Luke is going under a process of
learning via reaction but more
importantly he is slowly learning that
his lie is holding him back and as the
film progresses to be tested more and
more stretch out with your feelings
then comes the midpoint very bad feeling
about the midpoint in most films is
where your character switches from being
reactive to proactive in a new hope this
happens at an hour and three minutes
into the film almost exactly halfway
through its two-hour and four minute
runtime
this is where the Millennium Falcon is
tractor beamed into the Death Star and
after hiding in Han smuggling
compartments Luke discovers the princess
the princess she's here and makes his
first proactive decision to save her
belong to her she's the one in the
message we gotta help her this is the
beginning of the end of his
old self for the rest of the movie Luke
makes proactive decisions eventually
deciding to fight in the Death Star
battle even when he's told it's suicide
besides attacking that battle station
ain't my idea of courage it's more like
so why does Luke's art work how come it
doesn't feel forced and get it forced
well the easy answer is because it's
earned in his journey his lies tested
his decisions that pre him closer to the
truth to believe in himself are rewarded
Wells decisions that bring him further
from the truth and closer to his lie are
punished I've got work to do it's not
that I like the Empire I hated but
there's nothing I can do about it right
now
the decision to ultimately trust in the
force didn't happen magically it was a
culmination of events that started the
moment those two droids landed on
Tatooine but to all characters need such
in-depth arcs to make them work
according to Weiland your protagonists
the main character must have a strong
want/need ghost and lie to create
emotionally satisfying characters and
stories however your secondary
characters don't need to fulfill all of
these let's briefly compare Luke to Han
Solo and Princess Leia using the four
characteristics Han has a pretty clear
want to gain money to pay off his debt
to Jabba the hide tell Jabba his need is
to understand that friendship and honor
is more important than selfishness and
greed look I ain't in this for your
revolution and I'm not in it for you
princess I expect to be well paid I'm in
it for the money
his lies this belief that you got to
look after yourself if you want to
survive in the world your friend is
quite a mercenary one of you really
cares about anything
or anybody but Haun is missing something
a ghost does he need one no he's not the
main character but if he were we'd
probably want to know why he believes
his lies so vehemently although my guess
is that his backstory will likely be
rectified in the soon to be smash hit
solo found her in trouble there first I
can't but it's fine we're fine and what
about Leia her want is to stop the
Empire but other than that we never get
to flesh out her need lie or ghost in a
new hope her arc is not as important as
it is in the other films nor that of MU
upon and this one this changes in Empire
but that's a topic for a whole other
video so what have we learned from
Luke's journey we have a character start
in his normal world he wants something
but his lie is holding him back a lie
which is grounded in some sort of
traumatic experience or world view of
the past or present the journey will
test his life eventually turning him
from reactive to proactive and bringing
him closer to the thing he needs and the
thing he wants star wars is one of a few
films to effortlessly pull off character
arcs they're difficult to master they
take time planning and probably a lot of
coffee but if you sit down and do the
work you may just get memorable
characters and a film that will stand
the test of time
[Applause]
thanks for watching and if you like what
you saw please be sure to LIKE and
subscribe more videos on the way so stay
tuned